those were our best attacks and they did
nothing we can't be Robotnik as long as
he's got that Emerald he's too powerful
look we aren't strong enough to beat
Robotnik on our own but there's three of
us your strength your smarts and my
speed together that's how we win so we
make our stand here on the field of
battle as a team this is it
This is Our Moment
time to fight
[Music]
bad time to say this but I don't
actually have a plan
Tales any ideas we have to find his weak
spot
the groin what no no no provisionally
yes Ryan is the weakest spot stop
look out
I know what his weak spot is it's me I'm
the groin
[Music]
we're gonna have to work on your pep
talks pal
yeah let's go
all right mustache you want me
come and get me
don't tell me about coming and getting I
am on The Cutting Edge I'm coming and
getting coming down
oh you're really heavy that's because I
have one million percent muscle cross
the fox
let's go go go go keep going
[Music]
what the heck happened here
you think what I'm thinking let's go get
our kid